from 2012 to 2016
our team in Microsoft Research worked
very closely with the audio team at
Gears of War and our research help them
build a product that sounded more
immersive in an audio-visual sense Hey
oh we're not gonna talk about what
happened back there with the nest I mean
what the hell was that
hey oh we're not gonna talk about what
happened back there with the nest I mean
what the hell was wait you mean like
evolving shouldn't that take a lot of
time this research is just to improve
the end-user experience
computer graphics rendering is very
sophisticated it looks very realistic
but the sound up till now has not been
that you know it doesn't respect the
scene geometry when you combine the
visual and the audio cues you really
feel like you're in the scene the
technique that we're using with wave
physics is unique from a an approach
standpoint by using as your batch we are
also using the power of the cloud to be
able to make this very complex
simulation take a lot less time that
stands we are kind of modeling five
physical effects because we found
working with game studios and different
experiences that they seem to be like
the top five there are a lot more one is
obstruction which is to say sound waves
Bend around stuff then the second one is
portaling sounds redirected by the
environment around you the third effect
is occlusion which is just including the
initial sound and the reverberant sound
the fourth effect is reverberant the
fifth effect is decay time which is
simply that a bigger room reverberates
for longer we started talking about how
could we take the Triton technology and
actually bring it into games the amount
of
it takes to manually layout acoustic
zones in a game is really intensive now
you can just send that data off and all
your geometry and everything and you get
back to this data set a sound designer
can spend their time designing the sound
rather than manually placing acoustic
zones in the game within those that
space now everywhere I go there are so
subtle changes I might be closer to a
wall so I'll get more reflections there
my my reverberant will smoothly change
as I walk through the scene rather than
cutting from one place to another the
goal now for project acoustics is to
democratize this technology to get it in
the hands of as many game developers and
we are experienced makers as we can
project acoustics is essentially taking
the Trident technology and shipping it
in many different target platforms
developer sound designers can use it in
their own titles we think it's going to
be a faster way for them to get to the
point where they're shipping it's a much
more accurate way to do things because
the technology is based off physics and
from a design perspective it allows
creative people to be able to modify the
physical accuracy in a way that makes
sense for their experience
you